Je vais parler
d'une petite idée minuscule.
Et ceci est en un transfert de base.
Et parce que l'idée peut être expliqué en une minute,
je vais vous raconter trois histoires avant
de faire du remplissage.
Et la première histoire
parle de Charles Darwin, un de mes héros.
Et il était là, comme vous le savez bien, en 1835.
Et on pourrait croire qu'il chassait les pinsons,
mais non.
En fait il collectait des poissons.
Et il a décrit l'un d'eux
comme très «commun».
C'était le mérou voile
On l'a beaucoup pêché
jusque dans les années 80.
Maintenant, le poisson est sur la liste rouge de l'UICN.
Cette histoire,
nous l'avons entendu de nombreuses fois
aux Galapagos et d'autres endroits,
elle n'a donc rien de particulier.
Mais le fait est, nous venons toujours aux Galapagos.
Nous continuons de penser que c'est un endroit vierge.
Les brochures disent toujours
qu'il est intact.
Que se passe-t-il donc ici?
La seconde histoire, aussi pour illustrer un autre concept,
s'appelle le changement de tour de taille.
(Rires)
Parce que j'étais là en 71,
j'étudiais un lagon en Afrique de l'Ouest.
J'étais là parce que j'ai grandi en Europe
et je voulais plus tard travailler en Afrique.
Et je pensais que je pouvais m'intégrer.
Et j'ai eu un coup de soleil important,
et j'ai été convaincu que je n'étais vraiment pas originaire de là.
Ce fut mon premier coup de soleil.
Et le lagon
était entourée de palmiers,
comme vous pouvez le voir, et d'une mangrove.
Et il y avait des tilapias
environ 20 centimètres,
une espèce de tilapia appelé tilapia amrin sénégalais.
Et les pêches de ce tilapia
ont fait vivre beaucoup de pêcheurs et ils ont passé du bon temps
et ils ont gagné plus que la moyenne
au Ghana.
Quand j'y suis allé 27 ans plus tard,
le poisson avait diminué de moitié en taille.
Ils venaient à maturité à cinq centimètres.
Ils avaient été "poussés" génétiquement.
Il y avait encore des poissons.
Ils étaient toujours heureux d'une certaine manière.
Et les poissons aussi étaient heureux d'être là.
Donc, rien n'a changé,
mais en fait tout a changé.
Ma troisième petite histoire
c'est que j'ai été complice
de l'introduction du chalutage
en Asie du sud-est
Dans les années 70 - en fait, commençant dans les années 60 -
l'Europe a fait beaucoup de projets de développement.
Pour le développement des poissons
ce qui signifiait d'imposer à des pays
qui avait déjà 100 000 pêcheurs
leur imposer la pêche industrielle.
Et ce bateau, assez laid,
s'appelle le Mutiara 4.
Et je suis allé naviguer dessus,
et nous avons fait des études
dans toute l'extrême sud de la mer de Chine
et surtout la mer de Java.
Et ce que nous avons pris,
nous n'avions pas de mots pour cela.
Ce nous avons pris, je le sais maintenant,
est le fond de la mer.
Et 90 pour cent de nos prises
étaient des éponges,
d'autres animaux qui sont fixés sur le fond.
Et en fait la plupart des poissons,
ils sont une petite tache sur les débris,
les tas de débris, étaient des poissons des récifs coralliens.
Essentiellement, le fond de la mer arrivait sur le pont
puis était déversé.
Et ces photos sont extraordinaires
parce que cette transition est très rapide.
En moins d'un an, vous faites une étude
et puis la pêche commerciale commence.
Le fond est transformé
dans ce cas, d'un fond dur ou d'un corail mou
en un fond boueux.
Il s'agit d'une tortue morte.
Elles n'ont pas été mangé, on les a jetées parce qu'elles étaient mortes.
Et une fois, nous en avons pris une vivante.
Elle n'était pas encore noyée.
Et puis ils ont voulu la tuer parce qu'elle était bonne à manger.
Cette montagne de débris
est en fait ramassée par les pêcheurs
chaque fois qu'ils vont
dans une zone où il n'y a jamais eu de pêche.
Mais ce n'est pas documenté.
Nous transformons le monde,
mais nous ne nous en souvenons pas.
Nous ajustons notre niveau de référence
à un nouveau niveau,
et nous ne nous souvenons pas ce qu'il y avait là avant.
Si vous généraliser ceci,
quelque chose comme cela se produit.
Vous avez sur l'axe quelque chose de bon :
la biodiversité, le nombre d'orques,
la végétation de votre pays, l'approvisionnement en eau.
Et au fil du temps ça change.
Ça change
parce que les gens font les choses tout naturellement.
Chaque génération
utilisera les images
qu'elle a reçu au début de sa vie consciente
en tant que norme
et extrapolera vers l'avenir.
Et alors la différence,
est perçue comme une perte.
Mais ils ne perçoivent pas ce qui s'est passé avant comme une perte.
Vous pouvez avoir une succession de changements.
A la fin vous voulez conserver
les misérables restes.
Et ceci, est dans une large mesure, ce que nous voulons faire maintenant.
Nous voulons maintenir les choses qui n'existent plus
ou des choses qui ne sont pas comme elles étaient avant.
Maintenant il faut penser
que ce problème touchait certainement les gens
lorsque dans les sociétés prédatrices,
ils tuaient des animaux
et ils ne réalisaient pas qu'ils l'avaient fait cela
après quelques générations.
Parce que, évidemment,
un animal qui est très abondant,
avant qu'il ne disparaisse,
il devient rare.
Donc, vous ne perdez pas les animaux abondants.
Vous perdez toujours des animaux rares.
Et donc ils ne sont pas perçus
comme une grande perte.
Au fil du temps,
nous nous concentrons sur les grands animaux,
et dans une mer ça signifie les gros poissons.
Ils deviennent plus rares parce que nous les pêchons.
Au fil du temps, il nous reste quelques poissons
et nous pensons que c'est le niveau de référence.
Et la question est,
pourquoi les gens acceptent-ils cela?
Eh bien parce qu'ils ne savent pas que c'était différent avant.
Et en fait, beaucoup de gens, des scientifiques,
contesteront que c'était vraiment différent.
Et ils vont contester ça
parce que les preuves
présentées dans une premier mode
ne sont pas telles
qu'ils voudraient qu'on les présentent.
Par exemple :
l'anecdote que certains présentent,
telle que le Capitaine Machin-Truc
a observé beaucoup de poissons dans cet endroit
ne peut pas être utilisée
ou n'est généralement pas utilisée par les scientifiques de la pêche,
parce que ce n'est pas «scientifique».
Donc, vous avez une situation
où les gens ne connaissent pas le passé,
même si nous vivons dans des sociétés alphabétisées,
parce qu'ils ne font pas confiance
aux sources du passé.
D'où le rôle énorme
qu'une aire marine protégée peut jouer.
Parce qu'avec des aires marines protégées,
nous faisons revivre le passé.
Nous recréons le passé que les gens ne peuvent concevoir
parce que le niveau de référence a changé
et est extrêmement faible.
C'est à dire pour les gens
qui peuvent envisager une aire marine protégée
et qui peuvent bénéficier
de l'idée que cela l'offre,
qui leur permet de réinitialiser leur niveau de référence.
Que diriez-vous des gens qui ne peuvent pas le faire
parce qu'ils n'ont pas accès -
les personnes dans le Midwest, par exemple?
Je pense que là
les arts et le cinéma
peuvent peut-être combler le vide,
et la simulation.
Il s'agit d'une simulation de la baie de Chesapeake.
Il y avait des baleines grises dans la baie de Chesapeake il y a longtemps -
Il y a 500 ans.
Et vous aurez remarqué que les teintes et les tons
sont les mêmes que dans "Avatar".
(Rires)
Et si vous pensez à "Avatar",
si vous pensez que la raison pour laquelle ça a tellement touché les gens --
sans parler de l'histoire de Pocahontas -
pourquoi l'imagerie les a tellement touchés ?
Parce qu'elle évoque quelque chose
qui dans un sens a été perdu.
Et donc ce que je recommande,
c'est mon unique préconisation,
c'est que Cameron fasse "Avatar II" sous l'eau.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)